madame la ministre vous voulez vous
exprimer je vous en prie vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président pardon je
voudrais je voudrais moi aussi si vous
me permettez dire quelques mots pour
vous dire d'avoir l'émotion qui est la
mienne d'être dans cette haute assemblée
aujourd'hui je mesure la responsabilité
qui est la mienne l'émotion aussi d'être
parmi vous je voudrais saluer parmi vous
des sénateurs que je connais bien que
j'apprécie et avec lesquels je me
réjouis de de travail et je sais qu'un
travail important a déjà été fait en
commission sur ce texte qui ad'ailleurs
amène le gouvernement à faire évoluer
ses positions et je m'en réjouis parce
que je sais qu'ici c'est un travail
constructif qui peut être menée j'ai
eues dans d'autres fonctions
l'occasion aussi de le constater avec
beaucoup de bonheur vivent dans le
ministre